le terrain en Ukraine qui lutte
désormais contre le froid un nouveau
coup dur pour les habitants qui ont du
mal à se chauffer c'est ce que nous
explique notre correspondant à Kiev
Gulliver Craig
dans mon quartier en tout cas il y a
l'électricité et le chauffage selon la
mairie tous les foyers de la capitale
maintenant sont connectés mais les
interruptions programmées pour le
rationnement d'électricité avant
continuer parce que le système le réseau
est encore sous une très grande pression
à travers l'Ukraine dont 15 régions
d'Ukraine dont la capitale sur 24
régions au total on s'attend à ce que
ces interruptions d'électricité
programmée dure encore plusieurs
semaines même s'il n'y a pas de
nouvelles frappes russes et bien sûr
aussi on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait de
nouvelles infraprises parce que depuis
le 10 octobre c'est à peu près une fois
par semaine ou tous les 10 jours qu'ils
organisent ces frappes massives les
analystes estiment que c'est le temps
nécessaire pour les Russes de préparer
ces vagues de frappe alors vous voyez la
dernière grande vague c'était mercredi
ils ont mis jusqu'à dimanche pour
stabiliser le système même dans la
capitale
ukrainienne alors c'est une très grande
inquiétude pour les habitants de Kiev et
beaucoup d'autres régions d'Ukraine
aussi même si aujourd'hui la situation
est bien mieux qu'hier même si les
températures à l'extérieur sont en
baisse